let's bring in the aforementioned very
popular nick wright from first things
first on
fox sports one and he joins us uh thanks
for joining us what did you mean by this
cryptic
tweet what the media doesn't want you to
know about michael jordan
well listen dan and thanks for having me
on it's an honor as always
uh you know i blame you in part for this
oh boy
listen folks have a lot of nostalgia
tied to the 90s
it's you and keith on sportscenter it
was a simpler time and
the unbeatable chicago bulls and i've
always tried
like the great michelle obama to go high
when others go low
but i've had enough of folks bringing up
2011
and the mavs series i've had enough of
people talking about finals losses
so i just want to remind people of some
facts about michael jordan
did you know michael jordan never even
had a winning
regular season much less win a playoff
series
without scottie pippen with him did you
know that michael jordan
the only time he ever beat larry bird
in a playoff game was when bird was
coaching the pacers
did you know that in jordan's entire run
there were three teams in the eastern
conference that had an all-time player
on them
bird celtics isaiah's pistons shaq's
magic
jordan's series record against those
three teams
two and six against everybody else
23-1 and did you know that
after the pistons run was over those
next seven years when jordan won
five titles there was only one team in
the entire east because i was here oh
lebron walked over a week east
there's only one team in the whole east
that had more than one hall of famer on
it
jordenstein he's the only guy with a
hall of fame teammate reggie's got a
dutch guy who's 7-4 patrick ewing's got
john starks fresh out the grocery aisle
and people act like the east was great
it wasn't and so i just listen i don't
want to have to do a smear campaign on
michael jordan
who without question is at least the
third best player ever but i i i do what
i have to do
who is the best player ever nick come on
man
dan you know the answer to this i
the thing is this we we know it's lebron
and
it is going to be in 25 years folks
aren't going to believe
we argued about it it's like well one
guy was bigger he was faster he was
stronger he did it longer he did it in a
tougher league
he did it when the rules were kind of
designed against him
he did it over a far longer period of
time he scored more points he was
obviously the better passer
what were we arguing about oh the
the other what was it and so i don't
i don't think anyone can make a credible
case that does not involve the phrase
6-0 or bringing up now the 2011 finals
is i and i will admit this it is a
meltdown it is a
giant blemish on the resume but it's
been a
decade and since then he's played in the
last game of the year every year
except for the euro tour is growing i'm
with you
on recognizing lebron i don't understand
why he
is you know he's uh
polarizing yeah i i don't get it
i i don't know like of all the
superstars in all the sports
nobody faces this like lebron does no
there's no other big name star that we
try to discredit the way
even you know tom brady like people will
acknowledge tom is the greatest
they're not dragging him down at every
you know possible stop sign here
well and that's the thing is listen i
think there is a credible case to be
made
and that's why i said a little
tongue-in-cheek that jordan is at least
the third best i think there's three
guys with a credible case
and you and i have talked about this i
don't know if it was on or off the air
kareem gets totally disregarded
kramer's got the most points the most
mvps it won a finals mvp
16 years separated was the best player
in the league the day he
walked into basketball versus rookie
here day one is the best player in the
league
so karim's got a case obviously jordan's
got a case lebron's got a case
what bothers me is not the folks that
are like you know
i think lebron's second even though i
think they're wrong it's
it's your good friend and not as good a
friend as yours as he is to me but my
friend charles barkley was like
lebron's not top five i know yeah you
got you got paul pierce retroactively
kicking him out
of the top five because of a loss to the
blazers he didn't suffer
it's insane that stuff is insane and
i do think i don't know if he gets
points for this or not
but we saw in the last dance that
michael before his father was tragically
murdered
was burnt out and thinking about leaving
ahmad rashad told us he had that before
that he was thinking about leaving
and then at the end of the second repeat
was burnt out again and left
lebron has faced a level of scrutiny
unlike
any player ever just because of the
social media and the 24-hour
uh sports cycle we're in and has
showed up to work every single
day i don't think that can be discounted
i think the reason why barclay brings it
up and paul pierce brings it up is
how lebron went about doing it that he
had to go to miami
that he wanted to go to los angeles he
needed to bring anthony davis in
and i think that's where they look at it
and say you know
paul pierce benefited from kg and ray
ray going there or he never would have
won
and and charles knowing charles you know
he tried to do it in in
houston like they they did try
themselves
that's the problem and i listen i adore
chuck
but he's quoted in the houston chronicle
in the mid 90s
explaining why he's forcing his way out
of phoenix
because he wants a chance to win to team
up with clyde and dream
and paul listen paul's a very very good
all-time player i get it far better
player than analyst but
that was unfair but attack the but the
other thing is this
if you don't have kevin mchale gift his
old buddy danny ainge that's true kevin
garnett
then what's paul pierce like
he's he needs now he didn't have to go
anywhere
he was the dwayne wade in that scenario
with ray allen
and kg coming there but the idea that
nobody did it on their own
and lebron gave cleveland a fair chance
to build something
that first time around and they're like
hey how does booby gibson
and big z sound he's like okay i still
maintain
that might be now you could make iverson
76ers you could throw them in there
has anybody as bill simmons ever come up
with a list of the worst
teams to go to an nba final well so
listen the thing that iverson 76ers had
was the defensive player of the year
the chem bay was excellent like we
forget they they just didn't have a lot
of great offense
the 07 cavs were a disaster
trumped maybe only by the 2018
caps post kyrie posts the i.t trade
kevin loves in and out of the lineup and
it's it's lebron
and my guy j.r smith and jetty osman
like all right i guess we'll do this
together
i got a question for you i can give you
michael jordan at 25
lebron at 25 kareem at 25
and you're gonna build you're the
general manager you're going to build
your team around
one of those three oh i i think to me
it's unquestionable it has to be lebron
because he has shown
he is the only guy and this is the other
thing you didn't tell me who the coach
is
and lebron's the only one doesn't matter
for think about all the dynasties
not even just basketball dan football
all the dynasties it's an iconic player
with the iconic coach
lebron's like mike brown you want to go
to a finals hey
eric spoelstra who ended up being a
great coach you want to go he's going to
be a hall of famer though spoelstra i
think will be homeless
absolutely but at the time yeah you'll
never want to play off series
hey david blatt you're only going to
spend a couple years in america you want
to spend one of them in the finals
well hey ty lue you i think he's a
really good coach we didn't know it
frank vogel they got they couldn't get
rid of fast enough in orlando you want
to win a title it'll be fun come on come
join me
you know when your head was shaved
you're more of a michael jordan guy now
that you have
longer hair it just feels like now
you're you're you became a lebron fan
i think eight percent of the jordan
legacy
is the iconic shaved head and i think 14
of it is the sneakers i really believe
it like i'm telling you this
i am literally wearing jordan sweatpants
and i'm like damn
he did get the marketing done yeah
uh and i always wonder about this with
lebron if lebron had lost a series
like kawhi did you know we would still
be
we would still be talking about that
well like he's getting critiqued for
winning in the finals
oh of course of course so i think there
were two instances in these playoffs
where you saw
how hard it is to be lebron jimmy butler
was lebron for a night
and it was unbelievable in game five
yeah
and you know what it did to him it
ruined him for game six
because he was spent kawhi leonard for
the first time in his career
entered a playoff series where it's like
man if we don't win this
they're gonna crush me for the first
time in his career for a playoff series
he had to be lebron where it's like man
if we don't it's lose
there's no win for me here we're
supposed to win and if we lose i get
killed
and by the end of it he's going over in
a second
half of a game seven like that that
weight of the expectations that lebron
has dealt with every step of his career
it's pretty unprecedented and i and
we're talking to nick wright the co-host
of first things first on fox sports 1.
the thing that i bring up and i'll leave
you with this is
that we miss out sometimes because we
don't like a player for some reason i
didn't like bjorn borg
because he always beat john mcenroe at
wimbledon and i didn't appreciate bjorn
borg
and there are certain players you would
watch when you're growing up and you
just didn't
i didn't like the orioles they always
beat the cincinnati reds
brooks robinson frank robinson and i
just
i caution people you may not like lebron
for whatever reason
but appreciate this you'll never see
this again somebody who
at 35 reinvents themselves
and is still the best player in the game
and
he does it on a big stage in the bubble
degree of difficulty
crazy and we're going to still somehow
find fault with him
but yeah and you know what where that
really hit home with me and his great
point by you
is and i don't mean to bring it down at
the very end but when kobe passed
because i wasn't a kobe guy so i was
always nitpicking
you know what i mean i was always like
well what about this what about that
and i don't and i love basketball but i
don't think i
fully appreciated what he was doing when
he was doing it because i was picking
knit so i can be guilty of that myself
then all of a sudden he's gone and
you're
and when you revisit it you're like oh
my god like this guy
all the things he did so i do think that
is i think it's a great point by you i
wasn't much of a bored guy either though
seems like a jerk
i'm just kidding i wasn't alive good to
talk to you keep stirring hey
can i tell your audience one thing yes
about you oh
dan patrick and i have never met in
person and dan patrick
on three separate occasions has called
me to check in on me see how i'm doing
and to give me career advice he is a
really really good man despite some
questionable sports takes at times i
want people to know that thank you nick
i appreciate it thank you dan i
appreciate you i'll call you later
okay see you that's nick wright he's a
co-host first things first on fox sports
one